okay so today's video we're going to go
over the two processes colic
transcription and translation so let's
go ahead and get started okay so let's
go ahead and start off with the process
of transcription you know this is the
process where our cells will create RNA
using a DNA template you know template
is like a mold and so this process is
going to take place inside the nucleus
of our cells so let's zoom on into the
nucleus and here's a strip of DNA notice
how adenine pairs to thymine and
cytosine pairs to guanine well during
the process of transcription you know
here is an enzyme with the name of RNA
polymerase RNA polymerase plays a really
important role in this process
RNA polymerase is actually going to like
act like a pair of pliers and pry apart
the a from the T the C from the G breaks
the hydrogen bonds that hold the DNA
bases the DNA nucleotides together and
once that happens RNA nucleotides are
going to match to the now unpaired DNA
and so for instance notice how in read
the letters Aug just floated on in and
matched to the DNA letters of T AC and
so what we have here is a growing chain
of RNA in red and actually this is going
to be a growing chain of messenger RNA
here in red
well the enzyme RNA polymerase continues
down the length of the DNA helix and
continues to pry apart the DNA double
helix and that exposes more and more and
more unpaired DNA bases for mRNA to
match and bond with and down the length
of the double helix this proceeds RNA
polymerase prying apart the DNA mRNA in
red matching up and notice what just
happened at the back end is the DNA
starts to zip and come back together
so the process continues down the entire
length where the enzyme RNA polymerase
breaks apart the DNA that exposes
unpaired DNA bases in black so in red
the mRNA bases are going to match with
the black DNA bases at the back end the
DNA begins to come back together kind of
resist itself and again the process
continues with the enzyme RNA polymerase
breaking apart the A's and the T's in
the season the G's the mRNA is added to
the growing chain and at the back end of
the DNA it starts to zip and come back
together and so as we reach the end of
this transcription process the RNA
polymerase will pry apart the DNA
letters in this case AC T the AC T is
exposed and along comes RNA UGA at the
back end the DNA zips back together and
now that we've reached the end the RNA
polymerase simply detaches and the rest
of the DNA can bind back together well
what happens next is the RNA is going to
exit the nucleus and travel to a
ribosome so there goes the RNA that was
just created it's going to a ribosome
now when we get to the ribosome we're
going to pick up the process of
translation so let's go into that next
so before I get into the translation I
want to point out a few items you're
going to see in my animation well here
is a blue object that that's going to be
symbolic of transfer RNA or tRNA you
might know transfer RNA is called
transfer RNA because it transfers amino
acids to a ribosome there's 20 different
amino acids M et the green circle M et
met is the abbreviation for the amino
acid called methionine here is another
transfer RNA and it too is carrying an
amino acid this one's labeled pro PR o
PR o is an abbreviation for the amino
acid called prolene and finally here's
another has a third tRNA and it's Kerr
an amino acid abbreviated le you loop
stands for leucine so when you see these
know that the blue objects are the
transfer RNAs
and the green circles are the amino
acids notice how there are three letters
on the bottom of each of the blue tRNAs
these are called anticodons and you're
going to see why these are important in
just a moment but notice how the
anticodon is a part of the blue tRNA you
know a good idea might be to Google the
words genetic code because if you do
you'll get a picture that looks a lot
like this this genetic code chart this
is a chart of the twenty amino acids
you'll see prolene P R oh it was
abbreviated a moment ago methionine M et
was abbreviated a moment ago and this
chart is going to be very useful to us
when we start to go through the process
of translation so let's look at the
process of translation now translation
is the process of building a protein and
it takes place at the ribosome so what
happens is here comes the messenger RNA
that we just created a few minutes ago
during the process of transcription and
remember the messenger RNA exited the
nucleus and it's coming to a ribosome
what happens next is the ribosome is
going to read one codon at a time in the
animation notice how the letters au and
G are flashing Aug is a codon a codon
are three RNA nucleotides three
consecutive RNA nucleotides Aug is a
codon not only is Aug a codon but Aug is
a special codon Aug is what we call a
start codon it's the sequence that
begins and starts the process of
translation translation will begin when
the ribosome comes to the codon Aug okay
so the notes say that tRNA delivers the
proper amino acid but how do we know
what the proper amino acid is
well that's when we look on the genetic
code chart that you may have printed out
earlier
notice how the codon is Aug let's find
Aug on this genetic code chart I've
highlighted Aug Aug is the codon for an
amino acid called methionine so because
the codon is Aug transfer RNA is going
to deliver the amino acid called Metheny
M ET is the abbreviation for methionine
and so now I want to point out what the
anticodon is the anticodon are three
nucleotides that you can find on the
trna anti is a prefix that means
opposite notice how the a you G in red
is opposite of the you a C in blue
because they are opposites this is a
match this prevents the wrong amino acid
from being delivered at the wrong time
you'll see a good example of this in
just a moment notice what the ribosome
just did it went to the next codon the
next codon is flashing cau tRNA is going
to bring over the proper amino acid but
how do we know what the proper amino
acid is let's find cau on that genetic
code chart and so I've highlighted cau
is the amino acid called histidine so
now that I know cau is the code for
histidine I know that transfer RNA is
going to bring over histidine H is
abbreviation for histidine and notice
again how the GU a anticodon is a
perfect opposite match of the cau
codon this means that's the proper amino
acid and that allows the bonding to
proceed what happens is the two amino
acids will bond and the first tRNA now
that it has dropped off its amino acid
can just drift away
notice what just happened the ribosome
moved down one codon GGC is now flashing
tRNA is going to bring over the proper
amino acid but how do I know what the
proper amino acid is I look on my chart
I find GGC that's the code for glycine
transfer RNA is supposed to deliver
glycine so here comes transfer RNA
oh no it's not delivering glycine like
it's supposed to
notice how the anticodon G at the
anticodon UGC and the codon GGC they
don't match they're not opposites anti
means opposites this prevents the wrong
amino acid from being delivered so this
entire wrong
transfer RNA will drift away and that
will allow the proper one to come on in
and deliver its amino acid in this case
glycine and so now the amino acids are
all chained together and the tRNA on the
left has drifted away the ribosome
simply moves down to the next codon a CG
is flashing find a cg on the chart a CG
on the chart is the amino acid called
threonine threonine is going to be
delivered next by transfer RNA so here
comes transfer RNA delivering thr T HR
is abbreviation for three inning and
because again the anticodon and codon
because they're exact opposites that
allows all the amino acids to be bonded
together the tRNA on the Left detaches
and floats away it can be reused as can
all the others the ribosome moves down a
notch I hope you see I hope you're
getting the hang of this the ribosome is
now exposed GDU the codon ggu transfer
RNA will deliver the proper amino acid
so how do we know what the proper amino
acid is we look on the chart we find ggu
on the chart hey that's the amino acid
for glycine so now that I know ggu is
the
for glycine here comes transfer RNA
carrion GL y gly stands for glycine so
because the codon and anticodon are
opposite matches that allows the chain
of amino acids to be bonded together and
the tRNA on the left beats hatches and I
hope you get the hang of this
the ribosome simply moves down to the
next codon UGA is the next codon find
UGA on the chart and it's something
special
UGA on the chart is a stop codon it's a
sequence that will stop this process it
basically tells the ribosome the job is
finished so once a stop codon isn't is
encountered the stop codon ends this
process the tRNA will detach the
ribosome will actually break apart into
two smaller subunits and what you're
left with is a chain of amino acids
that's exactly what a protein is a chain
of amino acids created by the ribosome
through a process called translation so
as we finish this up just going to end
with a quick review here DNA through the
process of transcription is copied into
a molecule called RNA and then RNA
through the process of translation is
the code to build a protein so go ahead
and pause the video if you want to read
over some of the text and post your
comments in the space below I'd love to
read them and possibly answer a few
thanks for watching